Ready?
The US celebrated record high
school graduation rates five times in
the past five years. But test scores have
been flat, raising red flags about grad
rate inflation. Of course, schools offer
supports to students at risk of not
graduating. Chief among them: Credit
recovery, makeup classes that give
failing students a second chance to
graduate on time. While widespread,
participation is uneven. 39 percent of
all students taking credit recovery
attend just 8% of high schools. At that
volume, schools create a quality problem
where second chances become inferior
second tracks to graduation. But these
schools also have far more poor and
minority students, making this quality
problem an equity problem. Despite much
lower test scores and grad rates, these
peak credit recovery schools have the
highest graduation rate gains, bolstering
fears that lowered expectations will
leave many graduates unprepared. Done
well, credit recovery gives students
second chances. Done poorly, it offers our
least advantaged a second track that can
harm students and schools.
To learn more about my take on credit recovery, check out the link in the description below.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.